Okay,
here's the rats and this is from Yak
Panksepp's work,
right?
He was the first guy who figured out the
rest giggle and you might think,
well,
what kind of stupid thing is that to
study?
It's like $50,000
research grant for giggling rats,
you know,
so.
But he discovered the place circuitry in
mammals.
That's a big deal,
right?
It's like discovering a whole new
continent.
There's a place circuit in mammals.
It's built right in.
So it's not socially constructed.
There's A.
There's a biological platform for that.
And so what?
What?
What panksepp would do with rats,
he found out if rats,
if you take a rat pup away from its
mother,
it dies.
Even if you feed it,
even if it keep it warm,
it dies.
Now you can stop it from dying by taking
a pencil with an eraser on the end and
massaging it right?
Because rats won't live without love.
And the same thing happens to human
babies.
And we saw that in Romania when there
was that catastrophe have to Chesko in
the orphanages were the orphanages were
full of unwanted babies because Joe
Chesko insisted that every Romanian
women was constantly pregnant.
So the orphanage just stacked up with
unwanted babies and lots of them didn't
even have names and they were
warehoused.
Warmth,
shelter,
food,
devastating.
Lots of them died.
Most of them died before the first year.
And the ones that didn't die,
we're permanently dysfunctional because
you have to be touched.
If you're a human being,
it's not an option you have to be played
with.
It's not an option,
it's,
it's part of neurodevelopmental
necessity.
And,
and you have to also play fair,
so because otherwise you produce a very
disjointed child who isn't able to
engage in the niceties of social
interaction,
which is continual play in some sense in
reciprocity.
So what Panksepp did with his wrath,
he noticed the male rats,
juveniles really liked to wrestle and
they wrestle just like humans beings
wrestle.
They pin each other for crying out loud
with like that,
that have just lost.
He's down for a 10 count.
Right?
And so,
so what do you do is you take juvenile
routes and you can find out that they
want to play because you can attach a
spring to the and then they'll try to
run and you can measure how hard they're
running by,
how hard they're pulling on the spring
and then you can estimate how motivated
they are.
And so you can find out that a nice,
well fed rat who doesn't have anything
on his mind will still work hard to play
if it,
to enter a,
an arena where he's been allowed to play
before,
he'll work for that.
So then you think,
well the rats motivated so the two rats
go out there and they play and,
and so they're,
they're playing like dogs play and
everyone knows what that looks like.
If you're,
you know,
if you have any sense about dogs that
kind of go like this and kids do that
and maybe you do that with your wife if
you're going to play with her a little
bit.
My poor wife man,
when she,
she was,
uh,
she was uh,
a young.
She had older siblings and so she wasn't
played with as much when she was little,
as she might've been in.
Um,
I used to like,
you know,
if you take a pillow and you go like
this three times,
right?
That means look out a pillow is coming
your way.
So I go one,
two,
three.
Wow.
When she looked,
she was completely dismayed and he's
like,
what do you do that for?
And I thought,
well,
I eventually tartar that rule.
The other thing I used to,
the other thing I used to do,
you know,
is sometimes she'd come out and be like
this when we were playing around and I
grabbed her wrist and I know Parker her
hands through her knuckles together and
she used to just get completely annoyed
about that and I thought,
right,
that's what you do.
You just open your hands.
While she didn't know that either.
So she hadn't been played with enough
when she was a little rat.
So
anyways.
Anyways,
so you let the route,
the little rats go out there.
Right.
And so let's imagine one of them is 10
percent bigger than the other.
And so that 10 percent bigger wins
because 10 percent is enough in rat wait
to ensure that you're going to be the
pinner rather than the penny.
Okay?
So.
So that's fine.
So when the rat,
the rat pins the pins a little route and
now the big rat is the is the authority
rat.
And so then the next time that the rats
play,
the little rat has to invite the big rat
to play.
So the big rats out there being cool and
a little rat pops up and you know,
does the whole will you play with me
thing?
And the big rat will deign to play with
them.
But if you pair them repeatedly,
unless the big rat lets the little rat
win,
30 percent of the time the little rat
will not invite him to play.
And panksepp discovered that.
It's like,
I read that.
That just blew me away.
It's like,
that is so amazing because you see walls
first of there,
there's an analogy to Piaget's ideas
about the emergence of morality out of
play in human beings.
So that was very cool.
But the notion that that was built into
rats at the level of wrestling was,
and they're social,
they're deeply social animals,
right?
They have to know how to get along with
one another and most of their authority
disputes,
dominance,
dispute.
You don't want them to end in bloodshed
and combat because you know,
if your rag one and two and we tear each
other just threat shreds and the
dominance dispute rack three is just
going to move in.
It's really not a great strategy.
And so it'd be better if we could settle
our differences,
you know,
somewhat peacefully and so while.
So rats.
Anyways,
panksepp figured out that rats plan,
not only do they play,
they play fair and they seem to enjoy
it.
He also figured out,
this was really cool too,
that if you give juvenile rats attention
deficit disorder drugs,
Ritalin suppresses,
pray,
play.
So that's worth thinking about.
It's like,
well,
why do you have to give juvenile human
beings amphetamines in school?
Well,
because they need to play.
Well you don't,
you don't get to play.
They don't get to wrestle around.
I mean,
that's oppression as far as I can tell.
They don't get to wrestle around.
That's fine.
Feed him some amphetamines,
man.
That'll shut down the old place
circuits.
Well,
here's the other problem is Panksepp
found that if you don't let juvenile
male rats play their prefrontal cortexes
don't develop properly.
Surprise,
surprise.
You're not letting them mature.
It's like,
what else would you expect?
So,
you know,
that's something to think about really
hard.
I would say.